I am going to do two things today I'm
going to introduce an idea which we will
meet in a little more depth on Thursday
and then look at a sort of homicide okay
okay
so I want you to just look with me for a
second
just keep your look bad at this
quadratic formula here okay this
quadratic formula it took us a lot of
work together but it's worth it not just
because it makes this process so easy
like you hardly had to think compared to
this you just sort of do not miss an
arithmetic right but you also get all
these insights out of it so here's the
first insight I want to show you and
maybe if you wrote down the formula like
at it yeah just on the side yard I want
to rewrite this formula in a very very
very slightly different way like hardly
any difference at all we're gonna write
it like this it's one fraction at the
moment but I want us to write as two
fractions like so now if this is on the
same book that you were using last term
okay you actually have the lesson where
we derived this result we came up with
we started from ax squared plus BX plus
C equals y and then this is where we
ended and there's lots of algebra to get
there okay now this is actually one of
the lines we had might have in the
second last line in fact okay so what am
I going backwards what am I trying to
get back to this what I'm gonna point
out to you is that every travel and you
don't need to draw this but um
illustration every parabola every
problem is symmetrical okay every single
one this one is really super symmetrical
it's note is reflected across the y-axis
yeah and so if you look at this and this
way these are we call the roots are the
solutions of when is equal to zero okay
where intersects with the x-axis now can
you see if you have a look at the shape
right if you go from the middle because
this thing's symmetrical this distance
here to go to one of the roots is the
same as this distance here do you agree
with that like it symmetrical just like
just like hurtfully you know most of our
faces are symmetrical so if you go from
the center line you'll I this way is
like two centimeters
that way is 2 centimeters at least in
her otherwise funny right so this
symmetry here means these distances the
same now I can appear to a make sure to
see that but I can also appeal to this
line and you've just written down up
here ok have a look at it carefully what
is this mean you've got some number here
like once you've put in in this case
it'll be minus 3 over 4 so negative 3/4
and then you do plus and minus right
just like you did plus or minus as we do
for everyone right what do plus and
minus mean on this picture right plus
means going forwards right like if you
started from zero that was the middle
plus would be go to the right a little
bit and then you - which means go to the
left ok plus means good right - means go
there okay and how far do you go what's
that distance what's that 2 centimeters
it's like that I was talking out with my
eyes it's whatever this is equal to
which will be some weird number in this
case is the square root of 41 over 4
that's a bit weird but what I care about
is that it's the same right I go to the
right that much and I got on the left
that much ok so now therefore you can
write this underneath where you've
written this this little one ID here
which is that this formula which is
algebra tells me something about this
geometrically like this picture right it
tells me how two things first it tells
me where you remember I said it's
symmetrical right so tells me where that
middle is where the axis of symmetry
ok so axis of symmetry on my example he
was like really right down there on the
middle but I can move this to the left I
could move to the right and it still
have an axis of symmetry so where is it
it's this part here if that value that
you start from to get one root together
left to get the other one you go to the
right so the axis of symmetry is here
just that bit on the front - feed on to
a ok so for instance in this one that I
just gave you here if I had asked
you too please graph and we won't do it
for the sake of time but if I took the
same equation we said okay 2x squared
plus 3x minus 4 you see that's the same
question right I've just sort of labeled
it a little bit differently right if I
asked you to draw that thing where you
would find the middle of that graph the
middle of that graph is when X is equal
to minus P onto it which we've already
found this minus 3/4 okay so this graph
is sort of moved over the left a bit of
it because minus 3/4 is over that way
okay there's the axis of symmetry
but the other thing you can find with
the axis of symmetry is this point down
here this is a really important point to
the ground I starts with the beads they
don't know what it's called the vertex
very good you can think of it either as
like the bottom of the graph or if the
graphs upside down the problem is upside
down did be the top right so the vertex
is going to line up with this right it's
going to be in line with that axis of
symmetry so the vertex is located that
in line with the axis of symmetry so for
instance let's actually do it with this
question that we're just on question
form if I want to know where the excess
of symmetry is horizontally I'm going to
be at x equals minus 3/4 right I just
have enough space over here x equals
minus 3/4 that tells me where it is left
and right but it doesn't tell me where
it is up or down okay I need a y-value
how am I gonna get a y-value that
corresponds to this when we talk to this
equation right and I'm gonna take x
equals 3/4 then put it in in all of
these spots over here let's actually
just do it together now I'm gonna put y
equals 2 times this squared plus 3 times
this minus 4 okay and I'm just going to
crunch that number and that will tell me
where I am up or down 3/4 squared that's
9 over 16
so they multiply by two I think I'm
getting nine area Hey just doing this
all in my head so if someone's going to
calculate it you can tell me if I'm
doing it right
I've really lots of negative 3/4 will be
minus 9/4 UK with that I think I want to
get everything in terms of X because
that's the that's the highest fraction
I've got here so that's going to be 9
over 8 what's 9 force in in the terms of
eighths it'll be twice as many right so
I'm in a big 88 how many eighths are
there in minus 4 that's been half I
think it's 32 32 eighths
okay cuz 32 by the way is good ok 9
minus 18 minus 32 that's 9 minus 50
minus 50 so what is this what is this
it's wide equals this right so I've got
an X I've got a Y this is a pair of
coordinates okay so now I can put these
together minus 3/4 minus 41 over 50 and
that is where that vertex is that bottom
point there okay so I could graph this
thing off I wanted to but that's
something we'll focus a bit more on
Thursday okay